Hausa comb breads my knees this game is
based on an 80s horror movie and it
should be pretty [ __ ] funny I'm
actually really excited yeah back in the
eighties they know how to create
tensions is that me oh god about hai
Faria we're so glad you can come in such
short notice
let me take you okay hey why what was
that
before we go do you have any questions
yes why is your son running around in
the background talk when we get back
they'd really want to get rid of that
dolt why don't they said this is me oh
god what the [ __ ] am I got myself into
oh my gosh come back here there yes
there yes I see you blockage now you
have to find out how much control that's
how I walk to after I snorted bath salts
six and my [ __ ] tummy which
must think I'm a [ __ ] dummy
because I just blew me [ __ ] think I'm
broke [ __ ] I hate one Roach I made a
lot of money well it looks like we have
to find a [ __ ] remote control turn
the radio on yes did you have that billy
we're all gonna die a lot of money turn
on the TV yes the TV's on Oh
sitting down oh god it's a phone ringing
I know there was a phone there grandma I
told you to stop calling me goddamn sick
pervert Oh goddamnit
it's a grandpa again hello what do you
want hey Siri Jill you scare the [ __ ]
out of me huh hey remember that guy from
the mall are you gonna call him uh yes
you [ __ ] what are you going to what
don't judge me okay I'm not a [ __ ] I
swear I became I refrigerator
I hope this game wins an Oscar best game
ever you looking for death so creepy Jax
give that back you're gonna have to come
kitty oh god how am I gonna catch it
come back here baby I'm gonna cut you up
in little pieces and [ __ ] you out like
that
yeah dad got you now fine I'll give it
back yeah you better give it back
that's right five five five nine he
answers in a millisecond you don't look
oh hey Jack it's Sarah from the mouth oh
hey Sarah are you doing anything fun
tonight drinking smashing mailboxes
tipping cows standard boy behavior cool
hey I'm actually out of liquor we can
hang out if you have some I think I
can't Tom come over at 11:30
sure bye man teenage romance it's just
the best how do you know where I am
anyway open the liquor cabinet yes thank
you
it's locked damn it okay maybe maybe
bill knows something Mel yeah but then
open it okay it's away the key
I'll only give it to you if you cooked
me something you're lemaistre I need to
get rid of Billy let's kill him give me
the keys all right we got it
you [ __ ] [ __ ] Hey goes from big to
small no it goes from big to [ __ ] okay
yes let's give this Alison all right so
we have liquor hopefully now we can get
litter did it break it down now to me
Sarah girl she'll beat you before you go
sorry all right let's keep playing
oh man this [ __ ] game oh no Billy
Billy fell asleep better put him to bed
have you bros ever babysitting I haven't
somebody's ringing the bell unlock the
door yes
there's no one there what do I do I
guess I go out is that a white bear
oh oh oh god you're ugly you're an
[ __ ]
ha ha ha usually see the look on your
face well you should look at her face
holy [ __ ] I'm not talking to you hey
come on lighten up it's Friday night
it's Friday right so what do you want to
do well I was thinking we could you know
hey cool is that Night of the Living
Dead I love this movie
no just me senpai pls notice me senpai
so many [ __ ] rooms in this place holy
what was that I heard a noise in the
back yard so what so check it out
what if so is acting go look and now or
you ain't getting no titties fine he
just stops hello oh okay
oh well it sounds like he was actually
brutally murdered what happened to the
lice ha ha ha come over what nice angle
seriously really this is what you did in
games were you you were young try to
find an angle not who did that can we
take it yes and it immediately became 10
times smaller but chop chop chop chop
chop don't worry jack oh my god
chop chop chop chop chop are you okay
Oh God a screwdriver right in his oh man
he doesn't look too good he won't be
peeing for a while will you take the
screwdriver
I mean why waste a good jack
yeah stop being lazy you days coming oh
god what is he pushing something Oh God
look I don't know where I am this is
bullsh Oh God he's right there okay
don't panic
be cool everybody is happy there we go
go inside [ __ ] it's locked press action
actions
Oh
yeah that was [ __ ] intense man it
would be a lot easier if I actually knew
where the [ __ ] I was going oh god I
[ __ ] hate this okay what is the
action Billy Billy oh my god it worked
holy [ __ ] I didn't think that's oh god
what hey hey really are you trying to
find somewhere to hide why just do it
you pay so check I will chop you I have
an axe oh god oh god what do I know he's
inside that is inside big Hoss
I heard creaking oh god man please don't
kill me
if we go upstairs cuz that always helps
in movies hey kitty cat you're my only
hope
rusted open it yes what did I do
jump down the hatch now why would I be
crazy and do something like that okay
we're doing it Oh goddamn this is even
creepier than before why would I go here
hello
Oh God Edgar farted this is like the
worst scenario ever take the bolt
cutters what do I do with us
oh god that [ __ ] noise man shut up oh
god this is so [ __ ] scary Oh God oh
[ __ ] hello and I scare myself I'm such
an idiot
I do not want to be in Sarah's hits
right now let's go outside I think we
can use the bolt cutter on this although
she doesn't even cut to where the thing
is quality what are we even needing it
gasps yes mine cut the car is out of gas
yeah but I have gas Oh
gas up the car yes get in the car I
can't go anywhere oh god oh god he's
crazy he's crazy go go
my god am i what am I supposed to do
oh god his [ __ ] face why me
oh man the goddamn thought that tonight
Amelia medical God is coming hey coming
Oh Oh God
that sense [ __ ] that party's creepy bad
Billy I need you to run and find some
way to head why that's why [ __ ]
oh god this corner is [ __ ] creepy man
oh god help me
is that a VHS tape oh boy
that did I did I did it don't mind me oh
god oh god I'm gonna get trapped Oh
Oh Oh what the [ __ ] is he doing in here
okay let's try not get kill this time we
just need to make it up the space oh
you're serious right now
[ __ ] you where the hell it even come
from oh my oh there's the [ __ ] stairs
okay we're safe
I think [ __ ] karate chopping yeah
what if how did he mad at there like I
asked teleporting skills
don't wait held anyone can open that
door faster
record your favorite progress you don't
have a tape if anybody saw this foot
well that's too [ __ ] bad you piece of
[ __ ]
nice bug oh god shut up Billy I have a
gun [ __ ] anyone out there what where oh
come on don't you dare don't you ever
say all right bring it bring it
oh my god oh that is [ __ ] awkward man
now not Aquaman at all Aquaman Aquaman
aqua are you even paying attention
did you tap out I knew it okay here we
go and he closes the [ __ ] door oh
yeah
yeah baby you guess up that [ __ ]
oh god no where is he
Wow oh god I'm stuck now stop stabbing
me what am I doing with my life I don't
have any more ammo okay yes
Oh No if oh yes Billy I never been so
happy to see your ugly face man you look
like a tiny little Hitler let's get
outta here
what's the point of leaving now
he's dead thanks for your quick thinking
oh god she didn't even wash up did she
the kid is okay and your ass need a name
Jack I'm so sorry about what she says
that I'm so sorry about your boyfriend
huh was it his boyfriend what the guy
who attacked you is named Nicole Arbour
I don't mean to alarm you might what
what is it do you look like [ __ ] [ __ ]
I mean by the time my office arrived the
body was gone
but I told him it was dead I show you we
doing over Candy's ongoing investigation
in the meantime I'm gonna head to
somebody to take you deta hey stupid oh
yeah be safety
babysit a blutbad best game ever
I have played better games but man this
game was so fun I think it was pretty
funny anyway hope you guys enjoyed leave
a like if you did I really appreciate it
hit subscribe to become a broad today
aren't you a brother yet seriously
thousand breasts love you
you